- [Narrator] This UCSD TV
program is presented by
University of California Television.
Like what you learn?
Visit our website, or follow
us on Facebook and Twitter
to keep up with the latest programs.
(piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape.
Bipedal, naked, large brained.
Long the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts from
diverse disciplines to
exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible by the
generosity of humans like you.
(piano music)
- That's kind of a
gruesome picture isn't it?
But I like to imagine Darwin
in the dissecting room
actually helping us all out.
So this is a lecture that's
an experiment for me.
It's shifting the focus.
All of my previous lectures
about evolution and medicine
have been about traits, things
like height and pneumonia
and cancer and all the rest.
Today I'm going to shift
gears and try to apply
the things we learned about how to analyze
why traits are vulnerable to disease,
and ask instead why
genes that cause disease
persist in the genome despite
the actions of natural selection.
Evolution of medicine,
just to be very clear,
is not a specialized method of practice.
There's nothing alternative
about it whatsoever.
It's simply applying the well established
basic principles from evolutionary biology
to medicine and public health,
and trying to use them
to improve human health.
So the central question
I've been preoccupied by
is why do bodies have traits that
make them vulnerable to disease?
Completely different from the
usual medical research question.
Most medical research is about
why people are different.
Our interest is instead
about why we are all the same
in ways that are kind of like
the gas tank on the pinto.
There are things about our bodies,
from our backs to our appendices,
we'll get to that in a moment.
The first half of medical school
you must react with awe if
you're paying attention at all.
The loop of Henle in the kidney?
No details now, but oh my gosh.
If you're not astounded,
you're not paying attention.
Everybody recognizes
how great the heart is
and the valves in the right
place at the right time
and the pump does not need
to be oiled every few months.
The eye is miraculous in the fact
of its astounding function,
although it's not well designed.
The human hand is almost equally good
in terms of all of those
muscles and tendons
and joints working in tandem to allow
us to do amazing things.
The clotting mechanism had
better work well or else,
and then the part of
biology that I thought
was absolutely ridiculous and stupid
and at least made me mad
when I was a medical student
and now I find fascinating because of
taking an evolutionary
viewpoint, is biochemistry
and intermediary metabolism.
(audience laughs)
For any students in the
audience I assure you,
don't pay attention to your professors.
Go to evolutionary
thinking about these things
and it will make sense.
That's the first half of medical school.
Second half, you get to the
clinic and what do you see?
Somebody goofed.
You start off with the wisdom teeth, why?
You go further to the appendix, whoa!
You go further to the place in your arm
that always breaks when you fall forward.
Why isn't it bigger?
The coronary arteries, couldn't they
just be a little bit wider please?
And as for that birth canal, why not
just have a zipper on the
front instead of, it's,
and then there's the spine
as I mentioned before.
And the body could be so much better
in so many different ways.
These are traits, not genes, just traits.
And the old answer about
why natural selection
didn't do a better job is
well it's a random process
and it's not that strong.
That is absolutely one
important contribution
to why bodies aren't
better, but it's only one.
And a foundation for evolutionary thinking
in medicine has been to analyze
every kind of vulnerability
of a trait in terms of six possible
different evolutionary
reasons why we're vulnerable.
I'm going to list them very quickly,
and I've given many many lectures
about these applying to traits.
They're on the web if you're interested.
Today I'm gonna zip through them
and apply them to genes.
One is natural selection just can't do it.
Two is we're living in an environment
very different from the
environment in which we evolved.
Three is that pathogens,
bacteria and viruses
evolve faster than we do.
Four is trade-offs,
nothing can be perfect.
Everything can be adjusted in ways
that are better, but at the cost
of making something else worse.
Five, and this is a deep one.
Natural selection does
not shape any organism
for health, or longevity or
happiness or cooperation.
It shapes all of them for maximizing
their ability to transmit their genes.
Very disturbing idea.
The last is, useful defenses
that seem like diseases
such as fever, pain,
nausea, vomiting, cough,
and all the rest.
Now I'm going to shift
though my usual talk
and give up on talking about traits,
and ask about genes.
The focus of so much
modern medical research,
and ask why do genes that
increase risk of disease persist?
And the first thing I recognized
as I started down this path
is that we don't need to just
talk about the usual foci
of medical research which are the myriad
kinds of specific variations in genes
that make us vulnerable to disease.
We also need to talk about
genes that we all share
that are fixed.
Fixed means we all have it.
That make us vulnerable to disease.
This led me to just say
there's four different
kinds of genes we should
be thinking about.
First are the regular
ones, widespread variation,
all the regular genetic studies.
Two, variation between populations.
DARC is a gene that almost everyone
in Africa has because it
protects against vivax malaria.
Hardly anyone living in
northern climates has this gene.
Fixed or missing genes
for everybody recently.
Recently, the past few million years.
The one that studies Neu5Gc and GLO.
More about those in just a moment.
The fourth category is
genes that we all have,
such as genes that make bilirubin
and genes that make dopamine,
all of which make us
vulnerable to disease.
So a big shift in thinking here.
Not just variations among individuals
and their different genes,
but genes that we all have
that make us vulnerable to disease.
The first reason, limits of selection.
Lot of selection can't do things
and the biggest limit to
selection is mutations happen.
About 60 to 130 per
individual per generation
and a deep question for another time
is how on earth the genome
can fail to melt down
given the difficulty of
getting rid of each of those,
but they are all gradually
selected out by natural selection
except that natural selection
is by no means all powerful.
There's something that
geneticists call drift,
which is really referring
to random factors
that make genes become more or less common
just by luck of the draw, not because
of anything pushing them to
higher or lower frequencies.
This can result in good genes being lost,
and bad genes becoming more common.
Here is the biggest question
that faces us in medical genetics today.
We all thought just about 15 years ago
that the highly heritable diseases
such as schizophrenia,
autism, bipolar disease,
and things like diabetes and all the rest,
that they were highly heritable,
we know there are
variation in these diseases
is caused by genetic variations,
so we should be able to find the genes
and fix these diseases.
This has been one of the greatest
disappointments in modern medicine.
We're making some progress,
but it was a huge disappointment.
This is a graph done by
one of my former students
and his colleagues looking
at genes for schizophrenia.
I say genes, what I really mean
for the technically inclined is alleles,
that is different variations
that influence risk
of something like schizophrenia.
These are ones that are
relatively uncommon,
and they have relatively large effects
increasing the risk of schizophrenia
by as much as five to 10 times,
but they're very, very rare.
These are alleles that
are relatively common,
and their effect on schizophrenia
is really quite tiny.
They increase the risk by 1% or 2% or 3%.
Notice that they all
fall on the same line.
Notice next that there
are no genes over there.
There are no effects.
There are no common genes of large effect.
What happened to them?
Natural selection eliminated
them is the main hypothesis.
But more important here,
all of these genes have the exact same
proportion of variance explained.
And that proportion of variance is .04%
which is an eensy teensy
teensy amount of explanation.
This has been terribly frustrating.
A gene that causes less than 5% of 5%
is not gonna get you very far in terms
of explaining these diseases.
Sickle cell disease has been the
exemplar for evolutionary medicine,
but I'd like to suggest to
you it's a very poor exemplar.
It's interesting because of the mechanism
that maintains the frequency of the
alleles that cause sickle cell disease.
It was first discovered actually in part
by people, colleague of mine at Michigan
Jim Neel and his colleagues,
and they pointed out that
when they went to Africa
and looked at the distribution of malaria
and the distribution
of sickle cell disease,
it was about the same.
And then they thought about it more deeply
in a genetic way, and recognized
something that's called
balancing selection.
This maintains the
frequency of the alleles
that cause sickle cell disease.
You have to have two of them to get the
sickle cell disease at
a certain frequency.
If you have two regular hemoglobin copies,
you're vulnerable to malaria,
but you don't get sickle cell disease.
If you have two of the sickle
cell kinds of hemoglobin,
you get severe disease, often dying young
and usually not being able to reproduce,
but if you have one of each,
and you're living in Africa
where malaria is common,
or around the Mediterranean
where it's common,
it's not just Africa,
you get some malaria protection
and anemia is not too severe.
These people do better in
terms of having more offspring
than these or these and this means
so long as that gene isn't too common,
if it gets too common then a lot of people
get two copies and it's terrible.
If it's really rare, no benefit,
but middle range, fascinating example
but again, it's not a great example
because what natural selection does
when these kind of things happen
is find some other solution.
This has only been going
on for 10 to 20,000 years,
and we don't have very many other examples
of balancing selection.
I say this because so
many of my colleagues,
especially in psychiatry are
constantly making up stories
about possible traits, like
schizophrenia for instance,
resulting from heterozygote
advantage or balancing selection
and there's really not
much evidence for that
except for other kinds
of hemoglobinopathies
protect against malaria.
There are a few others, but
it's not a common explanation.
Shouldn't be the exemplar.
Something that should be though
is something like dopamine.
You probably are all aware that dopamine
in the substantia nigra in
the brain and basal ganglia.
If you don't have enough of it and your
neurons are dying off, you
get Parkinson's disease.
It's common.
Why are we vulnerable
to Parkinson's disease?
Well turns out that it's inherent
to the nature of the dopamine molecule
when it's metabolized,
the dopamine molecule
makes hydrogen peroxide,
and other oxygen radicals.
These things, whenever they
glom onto a piece of tissue
fry it essentially.
Dopamine is an inherently toxic molecule
and we're not going to
be able to replace it
because it's been used to
regulate motivation systems
for about a billion years now.
No chance of changing that,
but it's also inherently dangerous.
There are built in protection mechanisms
in those nerves to protect
them against the effects
of dopamine, and when those
aren't working quite right
for one reason or another,
people get Parkinson's disease.
Second explanation, mismatch
with the environment.
We used to think that common diseases
were caused by common genes
and we would find them,
but that turned out not to be the case.
Hardly any common diseases
are caused by common genes
or large effects.
Most disease genes that have large effects
are what George Williams
and I have called quirks.
Quirks are not defective.
They're genes that have bad effects
only in modern environments.
And this leads to the paradoxical finding
that most highly heritable diseases
are caused by the environment.
Doesn't that sound odd?
Quirks, harmless in a natural environment,
cause disease in a novel environment.
Ken Weiss, a geneticist
says a widespread dispersion
of these common risk
alleles, they're benign,
so if that proves they're benign
so if they're associated with disease
this means that they're interacting
with modern environments to cause disease,
pointing the finger to the environment.
So next time the New York Times says
we found a gene for atherosclerosis,
it's probably a gene
that didn't do much harm
back in the environments of the sort
that Mike Gerwin has been studying.
It's a gene that interacts with
big macs to cause heart attacks.
Nearsightedness.
Whether you're nearsighted or not,
depends almost entirely on your genes,
so why didn't natural
selection get rid of them?
Answer, hardly anyone is nearsighted
in ancestral environments.
Something about modern environments boosts
their rate so that everybody who
has those genes gets nearsighted.
Three candidates for that,
one is doing close work.
Two is high doses of sugar.
Three, low levels of light
because of living indoors.
Yet to discover exactly what this is,
we could eventually cure or prevent
nearsightedness if we
could find the answer.
Scurvy, our ancestors didn't have
scurvy because they made their own.
Ancestors back a few million years.
They made their own vitamin C, but we lost
the ability to make vitamin C,
and we lost it right about here.
Owl monkeys, marmosets, and humans
and gorillas, we can't make it.
Lemurs and others can.
Why did that ability get lost?
One hypothesis has been that
it's just because we had
so much fruit in our
diet it didn't matter,
and that's a perfectly plausible one,
but other people have
suggested that changes
in this particular enzyme increase
our ability to store fats.
Very interesting to try
to answer that question.
Third reason is infection.
Pathogens evolve faster than we do.
It's too bad and it's amazing that
we can ever, ever outrun them.
Therefore it's very strong selection
to survive whatever kinds of pathogens
and infections are around, but whenever
you see a mutation that
gets selected so strongly
to prevent infection, you should look
very carefully to see if there might
be bad side effects to that gene.
Turns out that there's lots
of evidence about this.
A nice recent paper goes
through many of them.
Shows pretty convincingly
that each epidemic shapes
quite dramatic changes
in allele frequencies.
Furthermore it points out that CCR5,
you get HIV protection if you
have this particular mutation,
but you're more vulnerable to West Nile.
If you have an O blood
type you get protection
against malaria, but you're
more vulnerable to cholera.
We need to not think about
good genes and bad genes.
We need to be thinking about variations
that have costs and benefits.
Trade-offs, nothing in
the body is perfect.
Everything is a trade-off.
My favorite example is bilirubin.
Why make bilirubin?
It's toxic, it turns you yellow.
Turns out it's wonderful
at stopping reactive oxygen
species from burning up your tissues.
And people who have a disease
causing high bilirubin levels
have heart attacks at
half the rate of others.
Very important for practical terms
in a neonatal nursery, where kids
are routinely put under lights
for even mild increases
in bilirubin even though
that bilirubin decreases
the number of reactions
to oxygen species in their bodies.
Genes for aging, George
Williams pointed out
a new explanation that is they might
have benefits in childhood
when selection is strong
and costs only later in life,
the so-called antagonistic
pleiotropy theory.
If in fact we could eliminate aging,
and the mortality rate stayed
the same throughout life
as it is age 20, most of us would live
to about age 800 to 1,000.
Amyloid beta is the bad guy
for causing Alzheimer's disease
but it's demonstrated
recently that in fact
it's a potent anti-microbial.
Every single one of these
genes seems like it's
just a bad actor, but
it's there for a reason.
Not all are.
We shouldn't assume it, but we should
consider the possibilities.
And then our gene work,
he's shown that all humans
are missing a gene that our
primate ancestors all had.
That is one for Neu5Gc, and it turns out
that two or three million
years ago we lost it,
but we keep eating other foods
that have that in it, and it may well be
that causing it, that that
causes inflammatory reactions
which might be responsible
for the high burden
of inflammatory disease in humans.
It might be that the reason that happened
was to help us avoid the kind of malaria
that influences chimpanzees
because that molecule
is what the malaria
molecule, pathogen uses
to get into blood cells.
Reproduction can increase,
change can increase
reproduction and harm health.
Apo E4 increases
progesterone and reproduction
even though it causes heart
attacks and Alzheimer's disease.
Even BRCA gene, causing breast cancer,
has been said to increase
number of offspring.
And finally defenses, such as pain, fever,
and all the rest are
useful but at a high cost.
Wrapping up, why do disease genes persist?
The same six categories that proved
so useful in trying to
understand why certain traits
are vulnerable to causing disease
helps us understand genetic variations
and genetic uniformities
in ways that make us
vulnerable to disease.
Constraints leave us with mutations
and heterozygote
advantage vulnerabilities.
Mismatch results in
quirks that were harmless,
now causing disease.
Trade-offs come with benefits, but costs.
Pathogens create arm races.
Reproduction sometimes
shapes changes in genes
that increase reproduction
at a cost to health.
And defenses are dangerous and costly.
Again going back to four
different kinds of genes,
variations among individuals, variations
among human subgroups, recent
changes that we all have
such as losing the ability
to synthesize vitamin C,
and then other things
like dopamine that we all
have had for a very long time.
We need to be thinking
about all these different
kinds of genes and their ways in which
they make us vulnerable to disease.
This exercise of writing this lecture
was fun for me because it came out
with surprising conclusions
I hadn't anticipated.
First, there's a very high proportion
of disease vulnerability genes
that are shaped by benefits of
protecting against infection,
and two they persist because of selection
for infection increasing reproduction
and extending lifespan.
Those of you who are
interested, we now do have
a scientific society of
evolutionary medicine.
It's called the International Society
for Evolution Medicine and Public Health.
We have a meeting in Europe
that you'd be welcome to go.
EvMedEd is a resource, and EvMedReview.com
offers news for the field,
including right now a meeting that's open
for anyone who wants to
attend November 10 in Berlin.
And information about jobs at ASU.
Thanks very much.
(pleasant music)